the movies that we make van and I are
van nice tat and I are you know a
communication aspects of the sculpture
they're like they're built like the
movies that we think are built just like
sculptures but they are their films so
they're they have they show the flaws
they're shot with a Canon t2i with a
missing with a missing pixel in the
middle about two-thirds of the way down
from the top of the screen you'll see
one red dot it's almost always there and
I think we're about to get a new version
like the t8i or something I'm not sure
but it's the idea that it's we we
started making movies when iMovie came
out because that and then when iMovie
started to become so difficult and not
functional that's when we stopped for
about three years and now reason Final
Cut because it's easy again what lenses
did you use because you had such great
intricate close-ups of drills and things
like that
which that's the off-the-shelf Canon
zoom lens I don't even remember the
number of it but it's probably something
like a 20 or 30 millimeter to zoom out
to be somewhere between 80 and 120 v
it's a good basic off-the-shelf one it's
not even the one with a red ring on it
it's not the good one I think we bought
one of those later when we had to get
another t2i
to take a picture of our t2i for the
credit sequence in the space program we
needed we needed a photo of the cameras
we had to buy a second one just to take
a one photo over the first one which we
then returned oh you did okay so the
entire film is shot on a Canon t2i baby
its name is baby Jesus and in the
credits sequence you'll see that credits
sequence is shot you'll see the camera
is in it so there was some iPhone
footage also but nothing there's nothing
exotic and when we shoot still photos of
the sculptures those are all shot with
like a 40 ninja pixel hustle
odd digital back by those are always
shot by Genevieve Hansen or Joshua white
those are stills and those are for the
images that you'll see in books and on
the websites what was the decision to
use a t2 I I mean I was thinking you use
maybe a red or something it's beautiful
but it really was what van hat that's
vans camera and what's important about
the t2 I to our team is that van knows
what all the buttons do and a red has
it's a probably a superior camera in
nearly every way except the have a huge
liability because it's so expensive the
virtue of a cheap camera is that it's
it's it's a it's not an heirloom product
it's a it's it's a consumable even
though cameras typically aren't
understood as consumables the film's the
data cards are considered consumables
but when something is that cheap you can
take risks you can you know you don't
have to take you don't have to obsess
about it and I think a lot of filmmakers
and camera aficionados are more obsessed
with the hardware than what it's
capturing and if something's only five
hundred dollars and you've got a huge
production ahead of you it's really a
relatively small part and that reversal
of economics and power is what gives us
the freedom to make a movie like we did
it's a bar lowering effect and and also
I can't underscore this enough the
knowing how to use the tool is the most
important thing not what the tool can do
as a sculptor I've made much better work
with lower quality tools that were in my
hands that I know that I have a muscle
memory with and a more precise better
tool just because it's part of my body
I'm not thinking so when Vans getting
these shots he doesn't have to worry
about learning about some great new
feature he just goes
you